you
[Music]
No Oh night Oh lalalalalala the Martin
Amana Joel Gargano support on something
about Madonna 80,000 bases across the
Redeem accurate Spanish okay before we
go any further this is a swiftly it's
the small brown and black bird whose
nest are a highly sought-after delicacy
here in the Philippines and people eat
them in a soup called well bird's nest
soup
typically these nests are found a high
high up on cliffs super hard to get to
and we've been taco Muslims in thousand
on fire attababy think it out son so
Bernie's birthday then Eddie didn't kick
them out instead he gave him half his
home similar salami Tamara detour 1993
don't see as a first floor now behind
operation Sanford Priscilla nest Lila
abu agela
saliva scent occasional epoxy a beer a
Badman and 10 minutes 20 minutes to be
legee parents ago so they boil it add
some veggies a bit of meat and voila
bird's nest soup little anchovy
pneumococci and a picto a shark in an
epic oh la la pasion that one more
[Music]
problem Alamitos Armenia pop insane or
nila yung a Marino vanilla pod ow mental
or dicks nah from a passive side of me
buying the kiya understandably so some
people they just can't appreciate the
smell of 80 thousand birds words of
droppings but Eddie in the swiftlets
have an arrangement
a tsunami bonus up friend Alana legacy
and deterrence in the negative the
Baha'i Byron birders inaba eirin de la
Frontera militant
[Music]
every time I take my Eagle out I get
butterflies in my stomach it's this
dichotomy between a heavy bird on your
fist that just instantly becomes lighter
than air you get to cultivate a really
unique relationship there very few
people flying eagles in the United
States and of that only a handful of
women but my very good friend Jamaica is
beginning her journey into Eagle
falconry the ability to be mentored by a
woman I thought that that was something
unique that I shouldn't pass up that
opportunity
[Music]
Falconeri is the ancient art and
tradition of using a trained bird of
prey to hunt its natural quarry in the
wild I spend a lot of time in Mongolia
apprenticing under kazakh eagle hunters
when I started I felt pretty out of
place because I didn't have that hunting
experience and I was a girl it made me
really fortify my passion and persevere
because it was hard in the beginning
I've admired her from the very beginning
her journey into falconry was different
than most the gumption she had as a
teenager to go to Mongolia and learn
about Eagle falconry that's a rare thing
a little over a year ago I got a call
from a friend who had found an eagle
standing in the road about a mile from
my house it was close to death so I took
it to the vet that afternoon and
participated in in rescuing that Eagle
falconry
is pretty much the only way at this
point and we know for sure allows that
eagle a reasonable chance at survival by
helping them through that period where
they're learning how to catch things I
made it my life's mission to get an
eagle permit and acquire an eagle
through an established rehab program
that works with falconers there's a lot
of knowledge involved in falconry
there's also a lot of ways to do it
wrong it's really not necessarily
instinctive I would not want to get into
Eagle falconry without a good mentor to
contact knowing that Loren was available
to be a mentor to me was
a huge part of being willing to make
that decision to get inside the mind of
an eagle the first time is a it can be a
difficult experience you just have to
find your bearings and understand where
an eagle is coming from in order to
create a good fit confident hunting
Eagle so essentially that's what I'm
helping Jamaica do when you find someone
that has that passion and is willing to
share it with you it's is really a
special thing the bond that you develop
with someone who gives a view their time
the way that Lauren is giving to me and
will be something I'll treasure forever
and hopefully someday I'll pass that on
to somebody else
[Music]
New York's a tough city to live in it
always has been
okay the old saying if you can make it
here you can make it anywhere I think
because the birds have made it here
I mean they've endured this far
my name is Steve Baldwin and I've been
tracking the wild parents of Brooklyn
for about ten years now
those two looks sort of frisky it's not
really that mating season but my upset
of Monaco's
the monk parakeet native to Argentina
and as far as we know something happened
at Kennedy Airport in 1967 from 1968
it appears that a crate full of parrots
arrived from Argentina something went
wrong a bunch of them escaped they came
to Brooklyn College right here we've got
an incredible cast of parrots here today
one two three four they're smaller than
it than a pigeon but larger than a
sparrow then the only kind of parents
that build these freestanding structures
these nests can get up to the size of
small cars it's methodical work its twig
after twig after twig parrots are sort
of the primates of the bird world
they're smart they're communicative they
eat almost anything that's available to
them so they're perfectly set up really
to thrive in a place like Brooklyn even
though it's not where they came from
they've adapted extremely well you have
to I think have a certain fiber of Steel
that to make it in this town and I think
the parrots have those qualities
[Music]
if you go into the water you see a great
white shark what's your reaction you're
not gonna think twice you're home and
asked to get out of there
Falcons are the great white shark of the
sky and birds are terrified of them my
name is Mark Adam I am the president of
Falcon environmental services our
company uses the world's oldest sport
falconry to protect planes in flight
birds can be really dangerous to
airplanes if a gull strikes an engine it
can potentially stop it in which case
the aircraft can come out of the sky
there are multiple methods that airports
can use to control birds
sirens another very common one is
pyrotechnics birds are not dumb they get
used to that stuff but one thing that
they can never get used to is the
instinctive fear of a falcon
[Music]
here we raise Falcons and when they
hatch out we rear them for three or four
days and put them back with the parents
the skills that we use to train our
Raptors date back to 3000 BC when
falconry was first introduced utilizing
hoods Jess's and conditioning methods
the birds are trained for about 30 to 60
days where then they go out to our
Airport operations
[Music]
on a given day they are requested
numerous times by the control tower to
intervene at specific spots on the
airfield at which time the Falcon is
deployed and it is allowed to fly around
the airport until the birds have been
dispersed when the falconer wants the
Falcon to come back all he has to do is
take out the lure which has a piece of
food on it swing it around his head and
they found can will come in in order to
be fed
I enjoy bird-watching but I find
falconry almost like a chance to see
something that happens every day in the
wild but I get a chance to see it up
close every day
[Music]
in the United Kingdom
you may ducks chickens geese and nah not
these they all belong to the Queen well
all swans in the United Kingdom can
belong to the Queen but she mainly
exercises this right on the river thames
of course sorry
[Music]
my name's David barber and I look after
the swans wherever the Queen exercises
her royal property fright it's not a
full-time job although sometimes it
feels like a full-time job every year
mr. barber runs a census of the Swans
for Her Majesty a bit like an annual
checkup this is called Swan Appy and he
does it with a whole crew like this guy
this guy and this guy sworn up in has
taken place since the 12th century where
swans in those days were actually a very
very important food of course today
swans are our protected species and no
longer eaten we travel in six
traditional rowan's gifts from some
Breann thames all the way up to Abington
and it's about a seventy nine mile
journey what do we say when we say s1 Oh
all up all up each family of swans we
come across we will circle the skiffs
around them we will tie the wings in
their legs we will take them ashore we
will weigh them measure them and check
them for any injuries after we've done
that we will put a ring on them and we
will release them back into the river so
if these are the Queen's swans ways her
majesty for all of this she did come
sworn up in a few years ago and
hopefully she enjoyed it she seemed to
enjoy it but I can't answer for the
Queen anyway I love swans a royal bird
people here in the United Kingdom they
love them and you know I want to make
sure that they survive for the future
all right gents let's toast grain